[Música]
i e da
a quem tem o direito de interromper o
[Música]
fim
há um nó na garganta que eu vou fazer em
que se pensa que é
chega de mansinho toma de assalto nessa
conversa revela um lado o comportamento
enraizado especialidade é cortar as asas
dela
[Música]
você não sabe perder
quando ela levanta te dizendo não não
sente a pressão da opinião de fumaça
história de submissão me pode ser melhor
que você
isso não é um problema
háháhá
não transforme a nossa liberdade num
problema seu
nem meu é seu
[Música]
a nossa força só cresceu 8 venceu a
nossa força só cresceu
[Música]
há quem entenda o direito de ti em
colher
[Música]
enfim a aaa
i uma lagoa ganta aqui que eu vou fazer
[Música]
vou a passarem
a nasa sant mais em raízes ainda mais
coragem todas nós é que se levante quem
desfaleceu nenhuma - nossa força só
cresceu cresceu a nossa força só cresceu
oi cresceu a nossa força só cresceu
cresceu a nossa força só cresceu
[Música]
e sobre a vida a quem tem direito sobre
o seu corpo
quem tem o direito que ensinaram a
obedecer a acreditar em padrões de
comportamento vestimenta beleza postura
atuação profissional relacionamentos que
disseram com base nessa sociedade
patriarcal o que é eo que não é adequado
para uma mulher geraram uma série de
desigualdades e naturalizaram a nossa
submissão nos transformando em luta e
resistência
só de existir eu não poderia deixar de
trazer esse assunto
essa música foi feita num momento de
muita tristeza e angústia logo após
saber que uma companheira nossa lá da
minha cidade havia sido morta
eu não conhecia pessoalmente mas sabia
das suas atuações enquanto musicista
professora pesquisadora militante enfim
ela foi estuprada e morta por um homem
que eu conhecia pessoalmente
a gente não tinha nenhuma intimidade eu
ele mas a gente sempre se cumprimentava
no mesmo rolê porque ele sempre estava
no mesmo rolê poderia ter sido qualquer
uma de nós mas foi ela não por estar no
lugar errado na hora errada mas por ser
mulher
isso não pode acontecer mais
basta de feminicídio mexeu com uma mexeu
com todas sim
ela em khan
ancara bem desse jeito jeito bem feito
do jeito que ela bem disso e balan
a e ela vem nos gado estilo bolado a
calma e bagunça
ela vai chegando devagar venho já
tirando todo a desmistificando tudo que
o homem insiste em falar ea sua roupa
ela escolheu não pediu pra você nem pra
eu porque ela entendeu que ela mesma
manda nesse corpo que é seu é e logo de
início eu quero falar do respeito nessa
mina do seu lado mas nenhum defeito
fugir desse assunto meu mano é uma me
conhece você tá achando que nasceu de
uma cegonha vem também aqui que eu vou
te falar
frida já se foi mas tem gente pra
representar e só pra gostar na minha mão
lembrar você é linda tem o jeito até
quando acaba de acordar o papa papel
dela papão e iaiá ei
o sol raiou toda essa guerra entre o
povo não parou
seu nome é betânia sua mãe é dona flor e
referencial de paz só tem o seu amor
só que o seu pode é todo dia a luta é
mais que gritam da massa profute com nem
procura o menino um dia não votava
também não estudava de casa ela saiu
para a rua foi armada armada de outra
tinha um menu escondia homem
privilegiado mas sistema ou premia um
salve brasil inac na luta botam fé
lugar de mulher é onde ela quiser
lugar de mulher é onde ela quiser trocar
de lugar de mulher onde ela quiser
lugar de mulher é onde eu aqui é o lugar
de mulher
é a de mulher é onde ela quiser a calma
bagunça e mostra bem como escolheu
[Música]
eis a mensagem clara e objetiva papo
reto ser mulher é muito forte mas nós
somos gigantes muito feliz em ver tantas
mulheres aqui falando com tanta
propriedade me sinto muito mais forte
para estar aqui por último ao longo da
minha vida eu conheci algumas semanas
comigo aconteceu assim eu conheci
algumas mães que já tinham entendido a
necessidade de um levante pelos nossos
direitos pela nossa libertação
isso aconteceu principalmente no
movimento estudantil ela já tinham
percebido que havia algo de muito
desigual acontecendo
e foram elas na vivência diária que me
fizeram entender o meu lugar nesse
mundão entender que esse corpinho aqui é
meu e que tudo que diz respeito a ele
sou eu quem deve decidir entender o que
é o machismo e como eles se manifestavam
em tantos momentos de um só dia meu
acharem justo querer que isso mude
libertad tantas responsabilidades que a
sociedade mim pois e que nada tinham a
ver com os meus sonhos ver a outra como
irmã e não como rival porque a gente
compete tanto outro olhar sobre a minha
mãe e às minhas tias a minha avó
as outras mulheres me colocar no lugar
delas em ti junto sabe e sobretudo mais
importante entender que esse movimento
de luta precisa ser intersexual preciso
olhar para todas as mulheres em suas
singularidades mulheres negras mulheres
lésbicas mulheres trans mulheres gordas
mulheres magras mulheres com
necessidades especiais mulheres mães
se você for uma mulher pobre
tudo fica ainda mais difícil foi o
feminismo
ou melhor mulheres feministas que foram
uma das principais pontes para a minha
libertação enquanto ser enquanto mulher
forte que eu sou e enquanto mamãe
o coração um sofá na minha garganta
serei mãe por toda vida então respiro
até que o peito e chá souto de pagar pra
ver se acalma o turbilhão escola de amor
também de paciência
sinto aumentar o espaço o meu coração é
grande até tem bem fala de outro assunto
teme não conseguir agora eu me pergunto
quantas mães guardar os seus dons na
gaveta a dia mais um dia que é hora da
teta e pra quem tá sozinho ainda é pai
ora preta já viu poder maior que o cinto
respeitar o espeto amal espelho
peço mais vida pra quem gera vida
mamãe espeto o meu respeito
dou minha vida pra te ver feliz da vida
a aaa
[Música]
o u1 da câmera matar não é que quem
gerou a cria não mais fria do dia cria
tintas e livros escondidos ele tem que
trabalhar passou batido por semana e
agora tem que aguentar criança chama
cidade mama quando ela lembra de quem
tem asas nem quem queira porta juízes
palpiteiros decretando o padre maab tem
força feminina fogo no pavio mãe terra
vida natureza mãe que te pariu como a
respeito
peça mais vida pra quem gera fita como a
rama respeito à minha vida pra te ver
feliz da unitau coração pulsa na minha
garganta
serei mãe por toda vida
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
muito obrigada a música como estratégia
de luta transformação e uma das formas
que encontrei para espalhar amor também
um amor forte revolucionário lá de onde
eu venho estado de mato grosso do sul
fronteira com o paraguai
em algumas partes o que acontece é que
uma vida vale muito menos do que um
pedacinho de terra
o que acontece é um genocídio com a
população indígena principalmente caiu a
guarani
isso porque o agronegócio além de
envenenar e matar e não nos alimentar
busca o crescimento a qualquer custo
e essa é uma realidade que eu também
procuro tratar nas minhas canções porque
esse problema é meu esse problema é
nosso ea expressão da sua arte é
resultado do que há dentro de você tem
correria que disfarça terra pra cima que
embaraça quem voa gente na desgraça a
aeon frutas ir andando lá pra cá só no
furtado incomodado
da terra ao povo fui tirado gente pedido
e não mal vatá a igreja de porta fechar
a dar
tem direito para quem o progresso vai
além
educa se preocupa com quem ainda não tem
e você vive pra quem deus não quer seu
vii acumulação furto
ana não pensa em ninguém
roupinhas rasgadas e os olhos fundos de
tristeza é o indiozinho e caminha
pedindo a sua terra e um pouco de
atenção descaso ou exploração desde a
colonização o sangue corre na veia gal
no filho do patrão existentes à cultura
firme em qualquer conjuntura lutando
pela justiça e puro a vida assegura mais
direito para quem o progresso vai a
educa se preocupar ae
ei com quem ainda não tem e você vive
pra quem deus não quer seu mistério
a mula sua fortuna
a não peça em ninguém e é sai e eu sigo
na certeza de que a música vai sempre
mais longe de que a minha voz ecoou um
acúmulo que é pessoal mas que é muito
mais coletivo gratidão aos ouvidos
atentos gratidão pela oportunidade vou
cantar mais um pedacinho
[Música]
a graça
te damos pela vida pela oportunidade
rica flora ser ouvida graças te damos
pelo amor esperança que inspira luta
contra o professor amarillo oi
jardel abriu sol entrou trazendo vida
inspiração do sul foi tcheco quem mandou
engate tão desenvolve a missão dá de
cara com um sistema grande julgar não te
dá a opção não tem progresso sem acerto
pense num gueto é isso eu te peço a
quebra da produção e é de qualidade em
agradecimento faz a arte da realidade
sogra até 100 a esse dia que foi dado
agradece aí a natureza eo cuidado
agradece novo dia nova chance de
recomeço
é
ei
muito obrigado
só um pouquinho aí assim ó ama também os
que vêm do gueto cuidar daquele que é
branco preto
meu deus é negro meu deus a índio deus é
mulher deus a menino ama também os que
vêm do gueto cuidar daquele que é branco
preto
meu deus é negro meu deus and deus a
mulher
deus é mulher
[Aplausos]